l'inter pince jouera aujourd'hui
[des rires]
le lapin ce qui se passe sentir par derrière
forrei xuxa stupidité dans le dernier autre
ce peuple deux et problème natuju
principales caractéristiques et passé
même de moi
le pied gauche est loin il peut si elle
il pourrait être sans eau
les feuilles mourantes n'ont aucune saveur et vous êtes
le remède dans le football pour voir voler n'oubliez pas
ce n'est pas la vie parce que le coton
Canapé turc si tu viens et ta fille
accompagne le
Et j'ai froid, regarde, tu es bon pour
tu télécharges fils je suis dans la vie droite et droite
huile de tritosa formée par une rivière florale
comment c'est
le téléphone prends soin de moi je peux ajouter plus tard
agrumes dans cet ordre 1